looks like the Rams back here
documentary films come in two shapes
long and short movie stars also come
into shapes male and female there are no
better examples of each then the dynamic
hero named Kirk Douglas and luminous
actress and the great tradition of movie
glamour Raquel Welch I'm sure you can
start tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen since they're all
looking at me
I just want to explain that this is
racquel
thank you yes I do I think they know
that well I just wanted to make sure
we're on live television and I don't
want them to make any mistakes we have
two awards to give the nominations the
nominees for the documentary feature
films are the children of theater street
robert dornhelm and earl mac producers
high grass circus build wind turbines
children and pony ian Zelo producers
homage to Chagall the colors of love
Harry Lasky producer million maids James
crying Julia Reichert and miles mogul
escu producers
who are the devotes and where did they
get 19 kids John Courtney Dan McCann and
Warren L Lockhart producers and the
winner is who are the devotes at 19
thank you very much I'm sorry that John
Cordy can't be here tonight I know he
wanted to be but I want to thank him and
of course all the d bolts and the
incredible film crew from San Francisco
that really didn't make this possible
thank you I want to thank John Cordy
also who's off right now doing all of
her story in Boston and couldn't be here
he was our director and we couldn't have
made the film it was his idea to do this
and brought it to us to Charles Schulz
and Snoopy for allowing me to do it and
all my staff at that office especially
to Sanrio films the people in Japan who
believed enough in this to finance it
and to help us do it especially to mr
sugi and Theriault jisu to the DeBolt
family who showed us the courage of that
brave family you saw in the film and
taught us who's handicapped and who
isn't
thanks a million
I knew I'd end up with one of these one
of these days and well shall we continue
via oh yes forgive me forgive me for
staring like hell but you know it's
funny but when I worked with Walter
Matthau Ernie Borgnine I never had that
problem but anyhow I'll compose myself
while you go right ahead
oh okay the nominees for documentary
short subjects are agua de Martinez our
people our country
Moctezuma esperada producer first
edition telling Whitney in do it el
Said's jr. pollution gravity is my enemy
John Joseph and Jan Stasi producers of
time tombs and treasure James our
messenger in Paul and among the
producers the shed and shetland
experience Douglas Gordon producer
gravity is my enemy
all of us that worked on this film and
all the generous people who supported
our effort we like to pay tribute to
mark Hicks for his profound effect on
all of our lives we would like to thank
the Academy for recognizing his
incredible talent and I would personally
like to thank my close friends
Joseph Quang and Stacy Schulman and my
cameraman John Shara
thank you it's a miracle that our film
got made at all and winning this is
another kind of miracle but the real
miracle was Mark Hicks the young artist
that you saw in our film that painted
his pictures by holding the brushes in
his teeth he taught us how to live the
life of a hero a lot of people helped us
Dean's Baroni the deans council the UCLA
art council ray Wagner so many others I
can't mention them all tonight the thing
about a quadriplegic is that they teach
you to live in a way that's different
than you normally do it's not our award
it's Mark's award wherever you are
tonight mark this is for you he's left
his wheelchair and is running free
somewhere in God's heaven tonight
thank you
50th annual Academy Award we'll be back
with evil moon safety Billy Dee Williams
Henry Winkler Natalie Wood and many more
after a station identification